all right news from the other side of
the country New York Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg says he will
present evidence to a grand jury
tomorrow against the migrants charged
with assaulting New York City police
officers it comes as Bragg faces
criticism for releasing those suspects
without bail but Bragg says our office
continues to work with law enforcement
to bring everyone responsible for these
heinous attacks to Justice we will not
rest until every person who assaulted a
police officer in this awful attempt
back is held accountable Maran Mendoza
is the mother of Sergeant Brandon
Mendoza who was killed in 2014 by an
illegal immigrant in a wrong way
Collision crash and she joins me now
marann good morning to you thank you so
much for joining us you know this exact
scenario that took place in New York
City is something that you've been
warning about for years and it's
personal for you because of what
happened to your son so first let's
start with your reaction to this footage
that shows these illegal immigrants
beating up police officers we learn that
a lot of them have criminal records and
then they get released without
bail um this reaction and and what
happened in New York is absolutely
what's coming next I mean it there's no
place else for this to go the illegal
criminals here in our country know that
they can continue crimes can commit
crimes they can shoplift they can do
heus acts in the United States and never
be held accountable and ala brg knows
that when you release an illegal
criminal like that they will never be
found and and as we've heard some of
them are possibly already in California
they assume another identity so this was
the worst thing that he could have done
and the state of of New York it's three
and a half years minimum for assaulting
a PE peace officer and these men will
will face nothing and you've got online
chatter by these Venezuelan gangs saying
we have control of your streets and um
you know I believe them I believe I
believe that something worse is is
coming down the shoot yeah and we're
looking at footage of these illegal
immigrants after they beat up the police
officers they went to jail for a short
period of time and now they're giving
the middle finger to the cameras giving
the middle finger essentially to the
country saying you know we don't care we
got away with it we've gotten away with
it before we'll get away with it again
and you know Maryann um reading about
your son he he is the exact type of
person that every mother would want
their child to grow up to be and then
his life gets cut short by somebody who
shouldn't have even been in this country
in the first place can you bring us back
to that bring us back to 2014 and what
you've been
through well Carly it it was the worst
day of my life obviously and Brandon was
a very integral part of our community
and it really affected this our
community of Mesa Arizona in the area
that he patrolled in a very a deep way
because he was a modern-day Beat cop he
did things for the community and you
know he he didn't deserve to die this
way and you know in May it's going to be
10 years that I have been bringing the
word out the unfortunate thing is that
that the attention span of Americans is
very very short they may listen to this
story on the on the news on your program
and say that poor lady lost her son you
know what's for breakfast it it it just
doesn't stick with people and for 10
years for me speaking out about this um
I really feel like America we need to we
need to wake up we are collateral damage
and we are becoming second class
citizens and the crimes that we have to
the crimes that we would commit as an
American citizen and the restitution we
would have to pay these illegal
criminals are getting off scot-free and
there's only so much America's going to
be able to take we're frustrated enough
at this government and marann the man
who killed your son had a pass criminal
record similar to these these illegal
immigrants in New York City who beat up
the police officers are you surprised
that this keeps happening and and what's
the solution
here no I I'm not surprised this keeps
happening at all in fact um it's
happening more than people realize these
types of stories are usually kept from
the public I'm sure that it's happened
many many more times in New York City
attacks on cops but they try and
suppress these types of stories um the
solution is to close our border the
solution is to get somebody in DHS who's
in charge who understands the mission of
Department of Homeland Security and um
until we get people who are willing to
stand up for American citizens back the
Constitution back the oath that they
took and do the job that they were hired
to do and that American taxpayers pay
them to do to protect us this is just
going to continue getting worse well
like you said a lot of these illegal IM
rants are already fled to California so
it looks like as of now they don't have
any intention of showing up to that
March 4th court date Maran thank you so
much for joining us and sharing your
story